there's no such thing as winning
business but if you listen to the
language of so many Business Leaders it
becomes abundantly clear that they don't
know the game they're playing in they
talk about being number one or being the
best or beating their competition and
this is a problem because when we play
with a finite mindset in an infinite
game when we play to win in a game that
has no Finish Line there are some
predictable and consistent outcomes the
big ones being the decline of trust the
decline of cooperation and the decline
of innovation we have to play for the
game we are in and most businesses play
with a finite mindset